who said i love you first we all know
he's a symptom i don't even need to
write my name again
we brought together six teen couples
we are a teen couple we are a team
couple
we are a team couple we are a team
couple we
are a team couple one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
this is odd man out
[Music]
how are you feeling i'm feeling
i'm feeling super nervous that's it like
i don't think we're gonna get voted out
right but deciding who to vote out yeah
i have no idea how you're gonna know
we're just gonna be ourselves be natural
if you know you're a couple you don't
have nothing to worry about
we got this baby
hey guys
let's not waste time how long have you
guys been together
uh two years and almost about two three
three months yeah
um we've been dating for a little over a
year and a half now
yeah we're going on a year and a half in
march we actually just had our one year
anniversary on valentine's day
we've been dating for 11 months our
anniversary is coming up in
nine plus nine plus three equals twelve
twelve days
we've only been official for three
months but we've been talking for
it's been much longer it's been much
longer than that
i think we can really yeah we've been
talking for like
seven years but we've been like
officially dating for two years
seven years seven years wait how old are
you guys again nineteen
yeah what took so long what's up i
wasn't allowed to date in high school
so how did everybody that was exactly
what i was yeah
i mean we met in high school yeah wood
shop class to be exact
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait laura josh wait lauren
josh you guys said you guys met in high
school but i thought you guys said you
were
friends for like for seven years yeah in
high school we met freshman year of high
school
yeah 19. i'm not good at math i'm
actually about to be 20 next month
i thought you guys i thought you guys
were talking prior though we've been
talking for seven months which is
freshman year of high school together
oh seven you guys said seven more years
wait did anyone else hear seven
oh yeah yeah maybe they got mixed up
everybody's a little nervous but we'll
just keep that yeah
yeah i'll give i'll help y'all out don't
worry don't worry laura and josh they
did not have their stuff together from
the beginning like come on
we even said like oh seven years like
that's hella long and they
acted on it i didn't even hear you say
that i didn't either because i was just
like they were kind of talking as i was
i think we're gonna vote for laura and
josh laura and josh yeah sadly you know
what
we ball zoe and kristen i feel like i
want to vote them
zoey for christian really yeah yeah we
are voting for laura and josh
for laura and josh aura
we're gonna get voted out
all right we have counted all the votes
and the couple eliminated
is laura and josh
i told you i knew it i called it
everybody makes mistakes you know
[Music]
this round is the relationship quiz
round i will ask each couple some
questions and they have to write
down their answers first up andrea and
jomo
first question who said i love you first
easy we all know he's a simple
come on bro i didn't even need to write
my name i didn't even need to write my
name
again second question what was the last
gift
your partner gave you bro um
so she got me a naruto necklace a gift
basket of all my favorite snacks and all
my favorite stuff
yeah i got her a polaroid printer for uh
like you could
bluetooth it to your phone and it prints
out like polaroid pictures of
stuff on your phone that's not like a
couple gifts yeah
a a little sauce next up zoey and
christian
first question what is your partner's
favorite ice cream flavor
bro this is wild enough mint chocolate
chip oh
mint chocolate chip mint chocolate chip
disgusting
what's your anniversary date give me a
minute hold on whoa why don't you have
to think about i don't know
i said in the evening november 11th at 9
00 pm
oh my god that's so specific all right
now with aisha and alec
first question who is the better kisser
oh
she was my first kiss
[Music]
second question what is your partner's
favorite thing about you
i'm smart i think he likes me because
i'm smart but i do like his smile a lot
that's part of the reason why he's also
very beautiful so
no way these people are in the bowl
there's no women i think they're
definitely a real couple
yeah now amelia and jonathan who has the
best fashion sense
i can dress no you can't you see the
dream immaculate
literally our first date was to the mall
if
[Music]
second question what is your partner's
favorite holiday
christmas i'm so glad we did get these
questions
mine's not christmas what no no
you're live not christmas
that's a big that's a big ooh no mine's
actually halloween oh yeah do you like
the dress i do like to joseph
it's all right everyone is usually chris
christmas is second we'll go christmas a
second
emily and jonathan you should know your
partner's favorite holiday
okay now blake and paul what was the
first movie you saw together
i don't know i was trying to think of
that one movie the one with the floors
what's it called
i think it's platforms
okay when is your partner's birthday
that is correct that is also correct
[Laughter]
[Music]
and last but not least gabby and daniel
who is smarter
oh no the question that's not a nice
question to ask
oh she has a job for this summer i don't
therefore she's smart
okay but you go so well on every single
test and you're always teaching me
physics
you're smart my guy don't forget that
and the last question
who is your partner celebrity crush yes
oh my god feelings are gonna get hurt
oh god oh yeah i know you put spells
in i put ryan reynolds i wasn't sure
yeah okay
he's basically me in my opinion but
we're suspectful
of um zoe and christian it kind of threw
me off how
they had to really think about their
date jonathan didn't know
amelia's favorite favorite holiday which
i feel like it's a big one
amelia jonathan i'm sorry you guys are
cute zoey and christian
amelia and jonathan yeah i'm sorry
amelia and jonathan and jonathan
zoe and christian i think i think that's
about it okay
all right we have tallied up the votes
and we have a
tie between amelia and jonathan oh no
and zoey and christian each couple will
have 30 seconds to state their case
zoe and christian you're up first um so
here are some things this is the ring
you got me
for valentine's day it's the stone from
new mexico he also got me this bracelet
ooh very pretty and i feel like the only
other way that i can
like show that we're a couple is doing
that
i don't really know what i want to do
you can't you can't buy love with money
that's all i'm gonna say i can't battle
up baby
you kind of explained more first off i
don't have anything that he's given me
because i don't
like stuff like that that's just not my
personality i don't like any like
promise rings or anything like that but
i've liked you since the moment
i loved you since the moment i've seen
you like that first
like something what i don't i think
you're adorable
wait but they didn't kiss on the lips he
kissed her forehead that's cute why
can't he kiss her on the lips let's just
do
amelia and jonathan christian we changed
our
vote to amelia and jonathan to the shoot
okay it's jonathan all right we have
counted all the votes and the team
couple eliminated this round
is amelia and jonathan
hey at least we are on this episode yeah
all i can say
[Music]
hey that was a stressful round
that was so stressful uh zoey and
christian because you were on the
shopping block i think we kind of need
to give you a bit of chance to kind of
talk a bit more what are all the things
that you guys have like
like amassed over this time like what
kind of things do you have my
valentine's day gift for him and it was
this
um personalized book it's called love
book i don't know if you guys have ever
seen it
but it's like a book where you like
design the characters so that they like
look like each other like it's like us
and then you make the pages and it'll
say like i like i
like this about you i love this or i
love when we do this together
we can sign off on that because she got
me the same thing too so that's a very
very real thing do you guys have
any traditions or anything that you do
as a couple like for us when we first
started dating we did like a pinky
promise video
every month every saturday we would like
rotate saturdays and we'd plan out like
a date day
so like one week went to like the
hollywood sign and then like another one
we just went like had a picnic on the
beach
and so we just like do it every weekend
like we switch it up yeah for us for
valentine's day
social media we met in a play together
so that's why we were the love
interests together and that's how we
kind of fell in love like on play and
then outside
for valentine's day the next year she
got us tickets to go watch the play
we were supposed to go to korean
barbecue but they were like hey why
don't we get popeyes
so now popeyes is our dinner yeah so we
get popeyes every valentine's day
comedy is kind of the thing that really
ties us together and because we had a
first kiss and then the pandemic came
and everyone got stuck at home
so we couldn't like hang out or anything
so we started watching a show together
every night and we'd watch an episode of
modern family
so over the course of like eight months
we like to finish
family we use this app called cena where
you can like watch movies
it's like netflix party so we watched
the entire harry potter series together
over winter break wait zoey and
christian how long did you guys say you
knew each other for
um well we've been official for about
like three-ish months
but we've been like basically together
since
september september october september of
2020.
can you use like a couple of words to
describe when you knew they were the one
and like ours would be like ice cream
date i think ours would be denny's i was
like reading the menu and i was like oh
i think i'm going to get a snack
and then i look right now
yeah i guess our words for a special
moment would be like yeah comedy someone
yelling at us kiss
we were sitting in the front of like a
show and then they were doing a little
skit where they involved the audience
and they came up to us and
clinton was like kiss kiss kiss and then
there was like hundreds of people around
us and we were like
oh my god oh my god but then i looked at
him and i was like well i've liked him
for so long and like
that's the hardest kiss
i think everybody's a real couple
honestly i like that andre and jomar
also watch modern family because they're
us yeah they're us
i feel like gabby and daniel are like
the canadian version of us
the couple that we're gonna vote out is
zoey and christian
sorry again andrea angelman yes
uh zoey and christian i say andrea and
jomar
we have counted all the votes and the
couple eliminated in round three
is zoe and christian
after the time and the
[Music]
overwhelming questions in the next round
i knew the target was on her back
definitely it was fun it was fun if
everyone feels confident that you have
already caught them all
you can end the game now if the majority
has doubt
the game will continue i think everyone
send it same
i'm honestly down to stop i'm pretty
confident
in three two one
i'm scared i'm so scared i have to be
right
[Music]
if the color that shows up is green you
all win
if it's red the fake couple is still in
the game
and they win in three two
one let's go
here we go the game is over and the team
couples have won
that means that the winners will be
receiving a cash prize
now let's reveal who the fake team
couple was
will the moles please raise their hands
in three
two one
you guys honestly did so great though
yeah so we are best friends everything
we said was true
we just added that we're dating in front
of it but everything wasn't true
jonathan had that forehead kiss on lock
i actually have a boyfriend so it was
really helpful to like
have that so he don't worry i have from
he had permission to kiss me if
necessary
we can all be friends or whatever yeah
okay we did it we finished we made it
oh my gosh okay so this guy has a
favorite couple
he just vibes with daniel daniel's my
guy
andrea and jamar like we just really
vibe with you know yeah
we are them they are us i feel like
people right now are
so easy and they want to rush into a
relationship
especially at such a young age once you
get to high school you'd be surprised
how many people don't date
i don't know i feel like as long as you
just love someone and that's like the
main thing it's like if you have love
for someone like you can be a couple
let's do a handshake for them ready one
two three
[Music]
you